alex ich möchte nicht so hingerissen der
impressionismus bin ich ja nicht du
weißt es und durch das viele geld was
geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja weil ich hoffe
natürlich euch jetzt gut und zwar bin
ich auf ein video aufmerksam gemacht
worden was ich mir unbedingt anschauen
sollte also das haben wir mehrere leute
geschickt und zwar nennt sich das ansage
an alex w und ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen so ich bin jetzt kein youtuber der
besonders auffällig ist oder so deswegen
ansage gegen mich gibt's zwar schon
öfter mal aber jetzt nicht so oft und
das meiste ist natürlich immer
kompletter blödsinn das wahrscheinlich
auch hier na ja also der fifa ist bio
verbot ich muss mal kurz einen kanal
anschauen ich habe glaub ich irgendwas
man von dem gesehen wir haben drei leute
geschrieben von denen ich zwei auch
persönlich kenne
das musst du dir auf jeden fall
anschauen keine ahnung wie die auf sowas
stoßen aber deswegen gibt es halt diese
reaktion dazu
der ist ja eigentlich voll gut dabei
kann man hier ansage an maßnahmen in
37.000 sogar rus hat er wahrscheinlich
auch eine reaktive video dazu gemacht
oder und hier nochmal gleich zweimal
das ist jetzt ein bisschen random aber
das war extrem witzig also ich wohne ja
in köln und gestern abend bin ich um 1
uhr zu bahn geladene batterie dass ich
jetzt vom thema abschweifen gleich
erzählt das einfach war ich bin zum
bahngleis hier weil ich meine ganze
klausuren fertig habe und dachte mir so
kommen du gehst mal in die stadt und
dann kommen mir einfach marcel scorpion
hingegen und ich dachte mir so dicker um
ein gut ist ja eigentlich kein mensch
mehr und dann einfach jemand den man
halt so ganz flüchtig über youtube kennt
ja könnt ihr euch vorstellen war ganz
lustig okay gut da will ich jetzt gar
nicht zu lang aber ich bin total
gespannt was er jetzt was er mir zu
sagen hat wir haben sogar 41 likes und
150 dislike also 41 leute unter
supporten das dass er voll gegen welches
zumindest einen punkt zum 9 2 wo ist
meine saftigen freunde das auf jeden
fall eine gute beratung service für
einen saftigen freunde an sag ich jetzt
eine anzeige gegen den typen
genau das habe ich mich auch gefragt
also ich frage mich wirklich in diese
ansage wie das fast genau kommt da jetzt
was kann mir vorwerfen ihn eigentlich
viele kennen und eigentlich nicht mehr
hält ja ich mache nicht mehr so fast
erreicht irgendwie hat mich in seinem
video mal erwähnt hat mir meine idee
er sagt dem anwender idee ja um eine
okay also er sagt ich habe seine idee
geklaut was habe ich denn geklaut ich
habe etwas gefunden kann hier
bürgerkriegen mystery bisher wusste
meine saftigen freunde willkommen zu
nehmen damit wartet mal kurz jetzt bin
ich ja komplett raus als ich hätte jetzt
ich weiß ich sehe auch nicht besonders
alt aus aber ihn hätte ich jetzt auf
1415 geschätzt und der darf schon
autofahren oder der sitze einfach nur
brot also der ist noch keine 18 oder ok
aber er meint dieses video we're back in
business wie vox habe ich von ihm
geklaut ich habe wirklich so ein video
dazu gemacht bessere box burger king
dann hab ich ihm das hochgeladen vier
tage später also da muss ich sagen ich
habe vorher mal nachgeschaut und
irgendwer hat so was schon mal hoch
geladen aber das war es jetzt nicht du
also ich habe es einfach nicht
wahrgenommen
sonst hätte ich natürlich ganz oben in
die überschreibung gepackt also sorry
wenn jetzt die ansage darauf beruht ja
nicht erwähnt weil er meinte ich bin ein
kleiner youtuber das habe ich also nicht
gesagt ich hab's halt einfach nicht
gesehen ich kannte dich ja gar nicht
gerade wie könnte man achtung ob es da
schon youtube videos zugespielt mich
irgendwie krass wundern wenn nicht
müsste reebok gilt vier videos zu dem
thema gibt es schon allerdings alle also
ich sag mal so es hat noch kein größerer
youtuber darüber berichtet hätte ich
mich jetzt zu den größeren youtube der
mich immer so zu den mittelgroßen
youtuber ich sehe ich jetzt mal klar
stellen im ministerium ochs dass sie die
wahl von mir klar ich will dass du das
bitte leicht ungehalten eindeutig ist
immer voll führerschein ich habe den
abschluss ich kann es mir gar nicht
vorstellen ich bin zwar denke das war ja
ein gedicht der deutschen sprache dann
weißte bescheid erst mal muss ich sagen
oder gar nicht explizit gesagt was ich
genau von ihr geklaut hat klar weil wenn
man mal alex wie mist in die box ein
gibt ich habe bestimmt schon 15 bisschen
wie boxen ausgepackt schüler das muss
ich mir jetzt selber heraussuchen dass
du das burger king video mainz und ich
glaube ich wäre es auch nicht lassen ich
weiß nicht oder saks löschen
alex ich möchte nicht so ein krasnaja
pass auf was du nicht du weißt und
möchtest für brillen und alles gute in
uns sonst auf der gamescom weiß bescheid
aber auch sonst gamescom weiß ja jeder
von euch ist meine absolute
lieblingsveranstaltungen ich als
vollblut gamer wenn natürlich seitdem
ich 13 bin jedes jahr auf der gamescom
meine lieblings messe wo man mich immer
antreffen kann deswegen wir sehen uns
dann alle auf der gamescom also wenn ich
eine bessere wirklich nur anstrengend
finde dann ist es die gamescom ich war
einer für fünf minuten drauf und wenn
direkt wieder runter gesprintet ich
konnte damit überhaupt nichts anfangen
obwohl ich zu der zeit selber einige
spiele die dort ausgestellt wurden
gespielt haben aber wenn ich mir die
schlangen gucken ob da ist es und ich
möchte dass es wieder ist alex ii und
dann alles gut sie damit uns wäre das
nicht läuft dann muss ich mal eine rege
dann muss gewalt ausüben oder muss ich
mich wohl bei die privatadressen locke
dann müssen wir ja gewalt ausüben ich
möchte keine gewalt ausüben
aber du möchtest dann bestimmt ich werde
mich da nur verteidigen alles klar das
macht auch wieder richtig sind ich
möchte keine gewalt ausüben aber ich
werde es dann tun und ich möchte mich
auch noch verteidigen ihr könnt mir sehr
gerne in die kommentare schreiben wird
jetzt an meiner stelle
würdet ihr das video im löschen oder
würdet ihr es drin lassen man muss ja
ganz klar sagen wir der bio verbot kam
als erstes auch die die mystery boxen zu
probieren eine seite ist immer wieder an
gm
so aber deine seiten sind ja gar nicht
auf null die sind ja bestimmt 0,8
millimeter lang seine hand sagen eine
kurze an alex ii folgt auf jeden fall
mal so einen typen der iss zu korrekt
auf instagram gehen noch ein bisschen
geschrieben der ist echt voll projekt
folgt immer ich habe den die
beschreibung verlinkt folgt alles klar
machen
wie ist denn noch gleichsam typen gucken
wir das ist gibt es gar nicht korrekt
von euch folgt mir auch auf ins tableau
von cfd heißt folgt dann auf jeden fall
das korrekte gut wenn ihr wisst das
video bis zum ende geschaut und dann
schritt hashtag der erde würde ich jeden
kommentar
dies mache ich doch glatt versteck
bioware boot
ich bin mal gespannt wie der sich
entwickelt schreibt mir auf jeden fall
mal die kommentare wenn das jemand von
euch weiß wie alt der typ ist also der
ist noch nicht 18 oder wenn ich mir hier
die bilder anschaue hier mein wahres
alter ein alter rené mein wahres alter
musik lassen
wir denken sich jetzt wohl endlich
zuhören ich hoffe sie ja nicht wie keine
zwölf jahre alt davor ich jetzt mal
waren alters öffentlich ein bisschen
über dieses thema reden
ok kommen lassen wir dass das was wir
dem video leute ich hoffe ich begegne
den bio verbot nie persönlich weil da
muss ich wirklich angst haben das ist
natürlich immer echt mental anstrengend
für mich wenn so eine person mehr im
netz droht ganz krass ich bin auch am
überlegen das ganze anzuzeigen weil er
hat ja öffentlich mit gewalt gedroht und
das ist ja in deutschland absolut
verboten naja mal schauen
das war's haut rein
[Musik]